le mouton est à l'honneur et avec lui
toute la filière de la laine
l'opportunité de re découvrir des
métiers oubliés comme celui de
tisserands installé depuis quatre ans
dans l'allier christian carrier a décidé
de travailler la laine à la main moi je
produis lequel il ne quantité artisanale
mail à tous et que je connais les
éleveurs je connais les bêtes
je sais exactement dans le troupeau
quelle est la bête dans la toison a été
utilisé pour faire une partie de ceux
plaide aujourd'hui plus de 80% de la
laine française par en asie pour être
traité avant de revenir en france
c'est en faisant ce constat qu isabelle
guillon a décidé de créer la fête de la
laine il ya un an
est ce que c'est la laine française
finalement que vous souhaitez promouvoir
ben oui et puis principalement alors la
laine française d'un côté et aussi les
la laine local des producteurs
qui se lancent dans la filière dans le
perche s'il ya des jeunes des jeunes
producteurs qui démarrent l'activité
donc ça leur fait une vitrine et cela
passe aussi par la transmission des
savoir-faire dans cet atelier les
enfants sont invités à fabriquer au même
un pompon en laine pour passer la laine
au milieu et après tournez repasser la
laine est retournée et ainsi de suite
voilà des poupons pas en france on ne
compte qu'une soixantaine de tisserands
professionnels